it seems like every day we hear a news
story about artificial intelligence and
how it's changing the world
like how AI can make your favorite
artist sing a song by another artist and
it sounds just like them
how AI is creating deep fake images of
the Pope wearing a puffer jacket
or perhaps more seriously how the phone
and Broadband company BT is predicting
it will lay off over 10 000 people in
the next decade because AI will be doing
their jobs for them
and it's not just software and customer
service jobs that are using AI it's law
firms accountants HR departments maybe
even news readers
so how worried should we really be that
AI will be coming for all our jobs and
what are our rights when it comes to AI
in the office
I'm Leah belletto and this is the Sky
News Daily
in a minute we're going to be speaking
to someone from the Trade union Congress
who've been looking into how AI is
already impacting the workplace but
first i'm joined in the studio by our
business correspondent Paul Kelso so
Paul talk to me about artificial
intelligence because I am a bit of a
skeptic and there's been so much in the
Press recently about the benefits but
also about how it's coming after our
jobs
how true do you think that statement is
first of all you're not alone okay in
being a skeptic because some of the
coverage recently has been generated by
the people who invented and developed
artificial intelligence in the first
place who are looking at the progress
their creation is making and wondering
if the the downside of this Great Leap
Forward in technology might be more
damaging than the upside of it and
there's a lot of discussion that's
really live right now about the impact
on the workplace because of the
effectiveness of some of the versions of
AI these large language models which
could effectively mimic human traits in
creating text and images in fractions of
seconds that is incredibly plausible and
sophisticated and
a lot of the time factually correct so
his AI coming after our jobs well if you
ask an AI that question it will say no
it's not it will say as an artificial
intelligence model I have no motivation
I don't do anything I'm not asked to are
companies using it to find efficiencies
to find productivity gains to make
working life they would take easier
absolutely they are because the
companies certainly the ones we've been
speaking to have seen it in action it's
being deployed far faster than they
thought it would be because it really
works so it's gone from the stuff of
Science Fiction to a fact of working
life for lots of people already okay so
Paul AI it's been around for a while
hasn't it but what changes are we seeing
in the last few months that's new
there's existing AI that we know about
you go onto a website you will be very
often been met by a little bot that
wants to ask few questions that's so
annoying they are annoying partly
because do you find them are they any
good never I always have to go through
to the human you end up at the human or
the frequently answered questions yeah
this is a different kind of AI
altogether this is stuff that is
generating
useful plausible
content material that companies can use
a couple of quick examples we'll be
speaking to octopus energy by the UK's
biggest energy companies a growing
company it's quite forward-looking in
the way it operates they've always been
interested in Tech they've been working
on a bespoke AI tool that's a little bit
built on chat GPT which you may have
heard of which is the one that the
recent developments have really
fast forwarded this debate because it's
so much better at stuff than the old
version that even the people who've
built it are surprised and octopus have
built this model and seven weeks ago
after some testing they started using it
to answer customer emails and it's doing
that from the base of it's read every
email octopus has ever sent to a
customer it's read every octopus
guidebook and handbook it's read
everything there is to know about energy
and energy regulation and law it knows
an enormous amount about money and the
entire way the company works it knows
everything it's read it all and it can
draw on it every time
in seven weeks they've gone from it
answering its first email to today it
answers 44 of its customer service
emails are they happy with it though
what do they say to you about well they
say when a human answers those emails
the customer's satisfaction response
rate is about 65 the AI does it
satisfaction is about 85 wow so it does
it better
freed up the people to work with cases
that it can't answer interestingly they
think it might be even better than
people are answering the complicated
questions so there is just an immediate
productivity gain and that in seven
weeks to almost half of the responses
that's sort of remarkable it's
incredible isn't it and when you look at
the workforce you think okay if they've
got this kit this AI That's improved
efficiency so much what does that mean
for the workforce at octopus for example
does that mean they don't need as many
people well Greg Jackson will say does
say that it doesn't mean jobs will be
lost what he does say is he's seen its
potential and he thinks for companies
where there isn't an upside in growth or
companies crucially where they're
seeking to cut costs AI is an absolutely
a means by which jobs could be replaced
and he described it as a freight train
heading to towards the workplace and he
thinks government need to act he thinks
everybody needs to wake up to this I
think that's what scared me about it a
little bit the speed of it
today do we know of any companies that
have used Ai and then people have lost
their jobs for example we've just heard
BT have said that they're looking at 40
000 jobs going across the board in the
next seven years and there are lots of
reasons for that sometimes because they
will have replaced all the Broadband
fiber and they won't need as many people
digging up the roads but 10 000 of those
will be jobs that they think will be
replaced by Advanced AI in due course at
the moment you still need a person a
human to check that there are not
glaring errors and that this works as it
gets better and it is getting better how
long that lasts is an open question yeah
um but Paul AI is being used in lots of
different jobs even in law firms Alan
and ovary one of the so-called magic
circle of uh British law firms long
established company more than 5 000
lawyers work for it it's been working
with a bespoke legal AI tool called
Harvey which is they described it um
slightly disparagingly it's taking the
fun out of AI by making it a legal
expert
everything about the law and they they
big area of expertise is financial deal
making banking okay based in the city
and so they do the the legal nuts and
bolts of company takeovers big deals so
hundreds of millions billions of pounds
involved there's huge privacy issues so
it's really highly technical important
stuff right it matters and they've
developed their own model which is
expert in all of that it's also got as
they put it all the companies
knowledge built up over years so it
knows how alanovery does business
and they're using it they've been
trialing it for
several months they started using it
three months ago
the day I spoke to them in the last week
they said three and a half thousand
lawyers in 43 countries had used it
again always check by a lawyer but they
reckon that's saving an hour or more per
person per week that is thousands of
hours of productivity gain I mean that's
the difference between the horse and
cart and the steam engine
you can see with those kind of
productivity gains why white collar work
is affected why companies are rushing to
embrace it and why it really is an
industrial revolution for White Collar
work but what we don't know is where
that balance between the promise and the
potential and the gains yeah will be
balanced against the harm and job losses
and where that will fall Technology's
always changed the workplace but it's
happening so fast in this case that's
where the anxiety comes about quite what
it means
thank you
[Music]
AI is already being used in businesses
across the UK and as Paul says a lot of
those companies are seeing great results
but what does it mean for the people who
work there
Amy Towers is an employment rights
expert from the Trade union Congress and
she's been looking at how AI is
affecting the way we work so Amy talk to
me about artificial intelligence are you
worried about it
so on the one hand we believe that AI
offers incredibly exciting opportunities
to better the world of work but on the
other hand yes we do have concerns about
the use of artificial intelligence at
work for the past few years we've been
running a project at the CEC looking at
what the implications are of artificial
intelligence being used to do things
that one would usually expect a human
manager to do so for example AI making
decisions about who to hire who to fire
who gets which work how they should do
it how quickly they should do it
where they should do it all sorts of
different decisions that usually a human
line manager would take
and our concerns are that using
technology to make those kinds of
decisions can potentially result in
inequality and unfairness at work we're
also concerned that using technology in
this way results in a loss of human
agency and control over their work
which can then lead to a negative impact
on workers mental health so we have a
range of different concerns and we think
it's really important that there are
sufficient Protections in place for
workers to ensure that AI is used for
the greater good and to make the world
of work a better place
me a little bit about how workers are
feeling you've touched on it a little
bit there but how has it left people
feeling when AI is introduced and it
isn't benefiting people who are in the
job
one of the things that came across
really strongly was a sense of
loneliness and isolation that people
felt when technology became too dominant
in their workplace
so a sense that there was a loss of
human connection and that matters so
much to people to actually have
in-person human engagement and
relationships and communication
and also we've seen so many headlines
haven't we about how AI or robots could
take the jobs that people are doing but
do you think that's true is that can AI
really take the jobs that people are
doing we think we're in a period of very
radical uncertainty where it's clear
that there is going to be significant
change
as a result of the use of AI at work and
automation
and at the moment the changes are
happening rapidly and happening across
many different sectors of employment but
what remains to be seen is whether that
is going to result in overall job losses
but that in fact a very significant
development and change will be humans
working alongside artificial
intelligence so that roles will
transform in some way and be changed by
the use of artificial intelligence
but how far in advance are we talking
here Mary are we talking in the next
year
the next six months I mean you know
because I I wonder how much of this AI
versus the the human is scaremongering
or how much actually we need to really
prepare ourselves with like you say this
radical change in Ai and how much it
will impact on our lives well there's a
certain amount that is already happening
so for example there's been an
announcement about significant job
losses at BT as a result of the use of
artificial intelligence so there are
certain changes that are already
happening
um generative AI has already been rolled
out in for example the use of various
different legal functions so that it's
undeniable that changes are already
taking place
but the fact of the matter is that
ultimately we need to ensure that there
are the appropriate Protections in place
for workers
so tell us about those rights in terms
of their current rights at the moment
that there are Protections in the
existing legal framework so for example
there are rights under the equality Act
that can protect people to a certain
degree against discriminatory algorithms
so that's where AI is making decisions
about people that are based on
some form of inequality that is in the
data that has fed the artificial
intelligence so that can result in
things like for example if AI has only
been trained on white faces then facial
recognition technology may fail to
recognize Black Faces I wonder Mary if
AI can do your job does that mean your
boss potentially could make you
redundant and AI could take up that role
there are really also important
protections for workers in terms of
potential redundancy so we're saying
that funding for reskilling and
retraining of workers is critical
um but we're also saying that whilst
there will be a change in the labor
market in certain sectors due to
automation changes that are already
happening that another significant
factor we need to consider is how do
workers work alongside Ai and how do
workers have a say in the development of
AI and that matters in all of the
different sectors of employment clearly
you're worried about this Amy and the
TUC is worried about it you know the
rise of artificial intelligence you're
calling on the government to protect
workers and their rights what is it that
you want from the government exactly
you're not happy with the current
legislation around AI is that right
the moment there just isn't
isn't AI specific translation in this
country
unlike in other countries so for example
at the moment the EU is in the process
of passing an EU AI act that is a
specific piece of Regulation that deals
with the use of AI across many different
aspects of society but in the UK we
don't have any equivalent and what we
say is we've got certain red lines where
we say that there just shouldn't be
technology in the workplace that people
don't understand when they don't
understand how it operates in relation
to them how it's making important
decisions about them but how much do you
think the package of legislation that
you've outlined there will have an
impact because it feels like we are on a
one-way system to AI just exploding
really and you've said you know job
losses here and there across different
Industries have we run out of time
we haven't run out of time there's
there's still time to act in every small
step in the right direction matters
and that involves everyone not just
trade unions but it involves all the
different voices in society making an
equal contribution and then us reaching
together a consensus about what the
right direction is for the use of AI in
our society
foreign
so as Amy Says people from all areas of
our society need to be thinking about
how we manage a world with artificial
intelligence
so Paul what is the government saying
about all of this as it stands
government policy is that they want the
UK to be a world leader in AI as part of
the Science and Tech being an engine of
growth so they want to be as open as
possible to developers they've published
the white paper which proposes no new
legislation at all and this burgeoning
industry which is going to affect us all
is going to be regulated vaporized by
existing Regulators so if it's a media
product it'll be awful yeah and what
they want is developers to talk to
Regulators to work out what's safe
what's not and do it with an existing
Frameworks I read the document and I
think that almost like almost everybody
else I'm not really sure where this ends
either they're not willing to change any
laws at the moment that's certainly
that's the official position what's
really quite difficult is to get a
handle on what laws people would change
and what they don't want from anyone
involved because the outlines of
where the threat lies and the threat to
jobs or whatever it might be not
entirely clear and you know if if AI
models capability stops where it is now
you've got something that can help you
do a lot of the the dull work of digital
data mining
throughout all sorts of research think
about that Acres piles and piles of
documentation produced in management
consultancies and lawyers and and Banks
and marketing agencies every day by
white collar workers a lot of that
could go away
but if it all goes away there's a real
question about what we do for work and
I'm not clever enough or well informed
enough to tell you where that ends but
it's clear isn't it we can't go back
it's a a huge revolutionary jump do you
think it's more about and I think I know
the answers is it's more about adjusting
us adjusting how we approach the
workplace that's certainly right
ultimately it comes down to what you do
with it yeah you say this is happening
in workplaces now right now
in a way that even three months ago the
company's doing it didn't anticipate and
we joke don't we that AI could it
replace our jobs Paul could it replace
us
it can already
write copy and text in plausible ways
but there's only one poor Kelso that is
true whether that's the good oral time
will tell thank you Paul not to talk
foreign
my thanks to Paul Kelso and Amy towers
and to you for listening to the Sky News
Daily with me Leah belletto this episode
was produced by Rosie Gillett our editor
is Philly Beaumont
[Music]